j'ai déjà chanté sur scène va m'aider
disons en 1953 j'ai fait pour la
première fois à mano ferentino de
florence de la médée de cherubini et
depuis j'ai beaucoup chanté ce rôle a
donc ce n'était pas une nouveauté et
seulement que depuis sa d'abord c'est un
rôle du monstre est tragique sans chant
et j'ai pas voulu mélanger exprès parce
que je n'aime pas qu'on dise que je ne
sais pas elle est capable
cette année je voulais pas mélanger le
drame avec le chant est alors tenté
mahama ma chance
seulement comme actrice et ça vous
paraît beaucoup plus intéressant
aujourd'hui de jouer au cinéma
sur une scène d'opéra c'est tout à fait
autre chose et pourtant c'est presque la
même chose parce que vous voyez dans le
tertre j'ai toujours rêvé
les premiers plans les gros plans parce
que je travaille de nuances et dans le
théâtre évidemment c'est tellement grand
que les nuances super il a évidemment
j'ai trouvé vraiment mon plaisir c'est
un rôle très difficile le rôle de milieu
oui c'est très difficile surtout parce
que c'est un rôle qui est vraiment sur
le lors de désastres dans le sens que
c'est très facilement un grand guignol
de la mesure où dit la classe comme dit
la divine est ce que vraiment vous avez
l'impression que leur dit le besoin de
prouver quelque chose encore non
vraiment non je travaille par le plaisir
de travailler je travaille parce que
sinon je m'ennuie mortellement et parce
que je suis une privilégiée
nous avons tous eu l'intention de jouer
deux personnages modernes après ça
m'amuserait bien pour je remercie s'est
ouverte à toute tentation